I think our honeymoon is the best party
that's true you know I'm surprising her
with a lot of honeymoon miss well it
looks like tanah mojo and Jake Paul are
putting their honeymoon plans on hold
we're so just about 24 hours since
Janice said I do in Las Vegas there's
already drama that was one of the
craziest moments I think of both our
lives on Monday Tana took to Twitter to
share that she's not leaving for their
European get away due to a quote family
emergency I'm gonna meet him there the
second I can so excited to decompress
from the past few months of chaos and
celebrate us with no one around but the
21 year old added quote my number one
focus is dealing with this family
emergency yeah sounds like Jake is still
on the trip I'm so excited
Tana goes on to explain that she was
disappointed by the really bad timing
but is trying to stay positive adding
that she doesn't want to quote take away
from all of the loves she was surrounded
by at their Sugar Factory reception
daddy's right et was exclusively with
the newlyweds immediately after they
said I do it was beautiful and its own
twisted Paul family wedding way where
the two dished on their post-nuptial
plans just getting out of flight
tomorrow yeah no idea I know I know
where we're going which i think is so
secret but I know that if anybody has
tricks up their sleeve it is Jacob
Joseph Paul and I'm not I'm nervous
are you two are gonna make the Instagram
name oh my god oh right dude an orgy
name versus like a 14 letter ball that's
just adding to the cloud thank you take
an adverse or unique card just by having
a short last name which is like and you
deserve it
I'm so excited about your pronounce
there's my way
I feel that be able to officially power
your white we've been calling each other
that census matters better dad but now
it's just real
[Music]